ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio
i am the internet detective guys welcome
today
we are hunting down a scammer who left
their phone number
while impersonating me in my own comment
section dude
the balls i can't believe the cojones
to do this to think that they're gonna
do this and get away with it are you
kidding me dude
dodge that as usual uh yeah it's right
here guys
it's all over my comment section this
has happened multiple times
and i never thought anyone would fall
for this so it's point number two is
interesting in terms of bitcoin gold and
stocks
it says it's coffeezilla of course it's
not me and they leave
their scammer whatsapp number with a
bunch of spaces
in it to get around youtube's ai
scam spam detection right because a lot
of these
comments they do go to spam like youtube
is trying to watch out for this stuff
uh but these scammers have found out
ways around it so my subscribers like
every single video are faced with this
which should be honest is a bit of a
test i mean if you're watching my videos
for real
you should not fall for this but
literally
some some of you have messaged me and
you go wait why are you
why are you telling us about this
bitcoin scam steve i thought you were uh
i thought you were against this stuff
and i'm like what are you talking about
and they link me this and i'm like
oh you're getting scammed in my own
comment section so i thought i'd finally
address it it's about time
and just because these people won't go
go away you know
they won't stop remaking new accounts so
i have i literally have to address it
otherwise
i feel like someone's eventually gonna
get scammed and i'm gonna feel really
bad
um literally even somebody that like i
talked to now and then
he's like yeah i texted back that number
you sent me
and uh it's kind of weird why are you
doing that
and i'm like dude you know me how do you
not know that that's a scam
there's even a check mark beside my name
uh
that says coffee's like it's the real
coffee zill it's like verified but
you know uh doesn't stop people from you
know i
falling for it basically and texting
this number so i decided i was gonna
text
it myself but not before being an idiot
and complaining about
about it on twitter basically i run an
anti-scam channel y'all making me look
goofy how hard is it to police the stuff
i tried flagging
and blocking um these kind of comments
because they're impersonating me and
literally it's not just one
account there have been four accounts so
far
that i know of that have tried
commenting on all my videos they all
have my profile picture
my username whatever it's so easy to
fake and impersonate people on youtube
and i've i i blocked four of them
probably more than that at this point
but um they they keep coming so i just
finally decided okay
what am i gonna do about it and then i
got this message
message the scammer for content and i
was like indie you're right
uh honestly you should have my job
because that's a good idea instead of
complaining about it online
like a wimp i should just do something
about it dude why am i
doing something so that's what i do guys
rather than complain
lest it be said that i'm a twitter
warrior i message this guy i say what's
up dude
okay but basically i wanna know what
this guy's telling my poor audience my
my unsuspecting sheep that are walking
into this
trap thinking that it's me you know
helping them out
uh so i say i saw your youtube comment
i'm interested in bitcoin stuff
my name is ben huge fan man he says
you've done well
to contact me regarding cryptocurrencies
investment
how long have you been into
cryptocurrencies i also do you invest in
any project yet
said i'm in crypto got a few bitcoin
whatever that's not true
but i just want to get them all greedy
right okay
i currently have an info to share that
can get you 12
daily returns do you know about
cryptocurrency mining
we're going to talk about how crazy 12
is but wow
that's intense daily returns are 12 i'm
i'm gonna be honest
you know i'm gonna be honest if you fall
for this you've learned nothing
it is kind of a test i'm almost thinking
of unblocking these
scammers i mean i'm going to continue to
block them but it's almost like a funny
test to put into my videos
like are you paying attention do you
know what too good to be true
means uh because if you fall for this
this is just
crazy this is crazy and he says okay
yeah i'm gonna describe cryptocurrency
mining basically it's this idea
that uh mike when it already did a video
about it's not making money you're
probably not gonna be profitable you're
just not gonna mind fast enough i'll
link this
video right here but basically this guy
sends me some random video of
a bunch of loud cryptocurrency mining i
guess
yeah that's annoying and then basically
tries to build some credibility
and then links me a website he says you
can verify we
are under regulation by bbb ftc imf
sec basically everybody this is finally
the web page
they give us to maybe go to and check
that out we'll check that
out in a second but i want to finish
this conversation real quick he says
basically
he wants me to invest five thousand
dollars worth of bitcoin into 12
daily returns i'll get 600 per day
according to this man
oh how nice of coffeezilla to hook me up
so eventually i want to press this guy
i want to see what he's going to do if i
ask him how to to prove himself
so i say my question is how do i know
you're real hello i honestly want to
invest a lot of money
can you send me proof i'm willing to put
down 5 000.
he says okay do you text on instagram i
say no send me a picture of yourself
so i'm expecting a picture of me pulled
from the internet
here's where the plot thickens who is
this
he says this is graham lisa message
graham lisa221
these guys are so confused and so
unorganized they don't even keep up the
scam of like it's coffeezilla
and even when you go to that instagram
channel it's like pathetic
the first line is human as if they want
to convince you
that this is a real person hey guys
first line of instagram bio we are human
i am not a bot it says they're from
barcelona the scammer which is probably
not true uh because later when we go to
that like
web address that they sent us initially
coin x mining
we find this coin x miner is registered
in the uk
so is she in the uk or is she in
barcelona of course
we don't know and of course there we
have a 12 percent daily
11 daily nine percent daily those are
their investment plans whatever
and they say yeah we're so legit we're
we're actually registered
with the uk government so i of course
had to look further into it there's this
company called
coinx ltd so i looked that up
of course and they give us an address
and so i look for their headquarters on
street view obviously i want to see it
is it registered no i don't see it
anywhere here so i end up hunting down
their little articles of incorporation
or whatever and we actually have a
different proposed address
here it's three high street instead of
whatever this was five
clerkin wall road so i say okay that's
interesting let's go check out
high street now unfortunately here we
also
uh have no luck so the best i can
explain it is basically this
uh this is some like virtual office or
something they did through a lawyer and
actually i don't even think they're
crypto x i think they're randomly using
someone else's crypto
you know company to front through
because crypto x ltd has its own website
which you can find here which looks
nothing like
coin x miner or whatever they sent us to
um and so literally they're putting
someone else's
you know registration with the uk up in
order to prove themselves legit
in the hopes that you're gonna of course
fall for it like
at several points during this operation
this scam
you could have seen through it it's not
it's not well constructed i'd give this
like a one out of five
in terms of persuasiveness it's so
obvious that this is a scam
but if you ever doubt it if you ever
wondered you know how do you know what
you know how do you know it's a scam
well i'll explain
they say they've been running for 1852
days
let's say i put in a dollar with crypto
or coin x miners and they actually do
what they say they're going to do
put together a little spreadsheet they
gave me 12 daily okay i put in the
dollar is everyone clear so far
it starts to compound pretty quick and
by day 100
you know i made a hundred thousand
dollars from basically uh
nothing from one dollar invested but by
day hundred 365
i have made uh wow
822
quadrillion
from one dollar this scammer
is gonna give me 822 quadrillion
now to put that into context i went
ahead and put the total market cap of
bitcoin because they say this is all
from bitcoin mining so the total market
cap of bitcoin right now if you owned
all the bitcoin
is somewhere around 600 billion dollars
you're barely moving a decimal place
but i went ahead and went further i said
what about the entire wealth of the
entire global population not like
your jeff bezos but you're you own jeff
bezos you own bill gates you own every
single person's wealth on earth
how much money do you have well uh 360
trillion dollars that's the global
wealth they
are saying that they will get you 2 286
times the total global wealth you could
buy the entire earth
2 000 times over if you invested a
dollar with these guys
for 365 days guys this stuff is so
comical
all you have to do is a little bit of
math and you will discover
that these guys are trying to scam you
um and it's really frustrating because
youtube doesn't give me a better way
to block these guys because they can
just keep putting up new fake accounts
so i decided
for your sake to just go through their
little scam walk through it and try to
show you
um how it all operates i will say
that i told the guy i told him to send
me his bitcoin address because i just
was curious how much is in his wallet
and i checked and there's zero dollars
in his wallet so this scammer has
fortunately made zero dollars so far so
you guys out there you get an a plus
i guess that's what this all comes down
to is that i said it was a test for my
followers kind of is
uh and you all have passed with flying
colors i guess no one actually followed
this through to the end
which makes me very happy because i
would hate to see you guys get scammed
um and just stay vigilant guys you know
there's a lot of scammers out there look
for that little check mark
because without it you don't know who
that is um and obviously if it's saying
weird stuff like
join this bitcoin scam or something like
that don't fall for it obviously i would
never tell you guys to do that
it's so against what i believe in um
to go ahead and join some weird cloud
mining setup so
that's it i'm never going to ask you to
join some you know investment scheme of
mine where you
get 12 daily it's never gonna happen i
know
some of you are waiting for that day but
it's not gonna happen so uh
yeah that's it that's basically it just
wanted to make a quick video about this
where i you know saw a scammer and i
texted him back so
yeah so thanks for watching and i'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]